we're looking at real estate especially
in the Seattle region Snohomish County
as I'm shopping for Real Estate or
thinking about doing airbnbs I actually
go to YouTube a lot for Market updates
but what is so fascinating Kristen there
is one person who's not even being
consistent but how many agents are up
there thousands so if you can punch fear
in the face and press record and if you
can say I'm gonna be consistent I will
until and I'm going to give this a good
effort there's so much opportunity
waiting for you by just starting messy
and starting to upload videos to YouTube
but um I want to throw my podcast mic
across the floor and be like Sean has
said it